[Music]
[Music]
so welcome to language animals and us
many think language makes us uniquely
human
yet bees communicate precisely how to
reach a source of pollen from the hive
were birds warn of a predator
dogs call to each other with their barks
and understand our verbal commands
and new studies show that baboons grunts
align with human speech patterns and
even plugs send signals to each other
through their roots
is human language just one type of
communication and have we wildly
overestimated its importance
are humans no different in principle
from other animals and plants
or is language profoundly different from
all other forms of communication and the
enabler of consciousness itself
with me to debate this fundamental topic
we have a great panel all of whom have
shown rather exceptional linguistic
skills themselves
joe cavanaugh is an award-winning and
acclaimed novelist whose books address
big social and philosophical themes
and amongst her novels in glorious a
field guide to reality and her latest
book zed
ray talis had an impressive career in
medicine and neuroscience before he
turned to philosophical writing
his books address what is special about
being human
central of course to today's debate
and include aping mankind and the
knowing animal
and jennifer ackman
is a best-selling author who's written
about science and nature for 30 years
her reclaimed book the genius of birds
was picked as one of their top books of
the year by the wall street journal the
spectator and the sunday times and
published in 20 languages her most
recent book bird way continues the
exploration of the complexity and
sophistication of avian life
i'm going to give each of the panel just
three minutes to address the question
is human language special or just one of
many forms of communication
so let's begin first of all with you joe
thanks hilary so as you know the
question is immensely paradoxical
we're trying to talk about a system um
within the system itself so we can't
really get an objective view of it um
language human language is completely
intrinsic to us we're inducted into it
from birth
and it's sort of something that's
preceded us by centuries even millennia
but then it becomes fundamental to our
sense of self and our consciousness
co-evolves with our acquisition of
language and so in this debate we're
attempting both to define human language
and compare it which is wonderfully
complex and paradoxical and i think for
lots of writers this question of
language language isn't really special
it's very um complex and baroque and if
you're james joyce you find it
horrendous really he said writing in
english was the most ingenious torture
ever devised for sins committed in
previous lives
and he felt very bound by these
historical associations of language
borquez said that language is a system
of signs which presupposes a shared past
and if you're resistant to that past
that can be very
much a struggle to try to find your way
in that caliban in shakespeare of course
sounds the quintessential complaint
he says the red plague rid you for
learning me your language for colonizing
me so there are all these echoes and
writing is a kind of fossilized poetry
language sorry is a fossilized poetry um
and that phrase is from owen barfield
and what i mean by that is there are so
many echoes and associations so many
ambiguities even in this question we
have just really quickly to define the
terms or attempt the most brief and
minute definition
language comes from the latin for tongue
lingua so it's a kind of synecdoche from
the start and the word special where
we're talking about latin again species
um but we understand it in the medieval
senses seer or favored um form is from
the latin figure or shape and
communication again communicare to share
so another way of phrasing your question
would be
if we use all these old associations is
the tongue dear or is it just one among
many shapes of sharing which we'd all
find a really peculiar question i think
to be debating so you know there's this
big
question ambiguity gap with language and
in terms of how um we're working
language and how other communicators are
working there's this really interesting
question which i hope we'll discuss um
about the gap that exists between
the experience of the individual and
what they convey and again you know this
this sense are we understood you know do
we convey what we want to convey
language and i don't know if a citation
creating an amazing sonar picture
of what it possibly perceives and
conveying that by underwater broadband i
don't know if that situation feels like
beckett at the end that they've sort of
failed and they've got to try harder
next time and i can't enter the mind of
the cetacean but in a sense i can't
enter the mind of other humans as well
um i'm really interested in citations
interested in the moving story of gnome
of nim chimsky um the chimpanzee who
there was a sort of turing test
experiment whether he could acquire
language and he acquired all sorts of
words um and was apparently able to ask
for a spliff but again we don't know if
he really wanted a spliff or if he
associated that with something else
so finally you know i think there's
enormous amounts too um
to address and just really quickly i'm
gonna really
really quickly answer your question i'm
gonna say yes human language is special
to humans vexing and
powerful and wonderful and difficult and
yes it's just one of many forms of
communication thanks
thank you joe
ray
hello hillary thank you well i want to
make three points firstly that human
language is fundamentally different from
any animal communication system secondly
that that difference is rooted in
something even more fundamental our
status is what i've called in a book
published many years ago as explicit
animals
and thirdly there is an abundant
evidence for the uniqueness of human
language and the consciousness in which
it is reacted in their countless
consequences evident in every aspect of
daily life
so let me list some differences between
human discourse and anything that bees
dance birds sing dogs bark or gem
human language has a syntax parts of
speech sentence correction this
underpins our famous capacity for making
infinite use of our finite means
combining and recombining elements
the signs of which human language is
composed are arbitrary in a profound
sense of being causally and in other
respects disconnected from the physical
environment and often indeed the
situation of the speaker
that's why we can talk of things that
are absent or non-existent enjoy mental
time travel
explicitly entertain and indeed
deny possibilities in discourse
we also distinguish questions demands
and assertions
and finally there is a linguistic or
meta-linguistic
self-consciousness in which we may use
language to refer to language a capacity
whose most remarkable if recent
expression is writing the encoding
storage and recording of utterances
that's the first point the second point
is that these features of language rich
complex and profound in themselves are
manifestations of
something unique about our humanity our
being creatures who make things explicit
to ourselves and to each other and i
hope we're going to talk about things
such as pointing and so on
but one aspect of this
is what tomasello and others have called
joint
shared or collective intentionality
an internationality is a property of
consciousness in virtue of which it is
about something
about something that we share
in a community of minds and a common
world woven out to a trillion cognitive
handshakes
and so to my third point
it might be argued that we are
privileged privy to the richness of our
own language
because we experience it from within
whereas we're not privy to the richness
of that of animals
how you might ask would a dog report on
human chatter
dismiss it nor as noise probably
we can however be confident of the
uniqueness of human language when we
contemplate its fruits
the wall-to-wall landscape of artifacts
the built environment shared expertise
institutions and other ways of
structuring collective activity laws and
rules that are consultant and argued
over as well as follow
a common mythical and historical past
and future
and also by the rapidity of our cultural
evolution and the advance of our
scientific understanding of the world we
are after all the only bit of nature
that puts nature in inverted commerce
but to preempt misunderstanding i'm not
saying that as a result of this we are
top animals
only that we are different in a
different way and one of the most
profound of those differences lies in
our language
uh jennifer
human language certainly is special i
don't argue that animals or plants for
that matter have language as we define
it in human terms you know we don't have
evidence for symbolic communication in
other species that's as rich and
multifunctional as our language
and um
as both rey and joe have pointed out
human language has a structure and an
open-ended endedness it's an expressive
power that's unlike
communication in any other species as
far as we know
but to my mind there
there may be a vast unexplored universe
in that phrase as far as we know
you know the field of animal cognition
understanding the minds of other animals
how they think and communicate is really
still in its infancy and we have a very
long way to go before we can say that we
fully understand how dolphins
communicate or whales or elephants or
cephalopods or even birds
moreover even if human language is in
its entirety unique certain aspects of
it i don't think are
i'm going to give just one example
one bird species out of 10 000 the new
holland honeyeater of australia which is
a bird that's toppling old ideas about
how much information a bird can convey
in its calls so when a honey eater spots
a threat like a hawk it makes an alarm
call that's packed with information
about the nature of the predator and
what it's doing
and it really makes you wonder what
we're missing in other bird calls and
songs
so scientists are finding also
language-like qualities
such as this in some bird vocalizations
the key linguistic features such as
functional referentiality the ability to
refer to a specific object or event in
the environment
and compositional syntax in a very
simple form
um
which is the set of rules for arranging
and combining sounds and words to create
meaningful phrases and sentences
and you know there are other parallels
between human speech and bird song
we've come to understand that birds
learn their songs the way that we learn
language through vocal learning
and the similarities are remarkable from
the process of listening imitating and
practicing right down to the brain
pathways involved and the actions of
specific genes in those pathways
and there are other ways that that
communication among birds may mirror our
own use of language for instance in its
powerful capacity to deceive and
manipulate
and we share these features not because
they evolved in a shared common ancestor
300 million years ago
but because of convergent evolution
birds and humans converged on strategies
and similar neuronal pathways and genes
because these are good and effective
mechanisms for learning sophisticated
communication
so in short birds to name just one class
of animals and may have forms of
communication that hold more meaning and
subtle language-like qualities than we
ever imagined
and the ways that we interpret and
categorize them may actually bear little
resemblance to how these animals
actually hear and use them
so the question that interests me is not
so much are we humans alone in
possessing language but rather do other
animals and perhaps even plants
have systems of communication that are
highly sophisticated with complex
characteristics that we don't know how
to measure yet
we don't have a rosetta stone for them
and that are perhaps at least at the
moment beyond our understanding
thank you jennifer thank you thank all
of you for such clear
uh positions that you've laid out
so let's let's begin by
looking at language
itself before we explore the issue of
the relationship with uh animals and
just get try to get clear
what we're talking about
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas